so as they desperately work to get Trump
off the ballot they're also working on
another contingency plan is this pant
Plan B C or D I've lost track making
sure that he's in court long enough that
he basically won't be able to campaign
now the judge on Trump's January 6th
case just set a trial date as I said
earlier of March 4th 2024. well if that
day sounds kind of familiar it's because
it's the same day the Georgia D.A Fanny
Willis wanted so she got what she wanted
now why is that day so critical it seems
like it's in high demand is there
anything else happening around the same
time
oh let me think oh yeah super Tuesday is
the next day let that judge apparently
thinks that doesn't matter uh Trump just
to needs to have to make it work
when you have a court date when you're
in the justice system that takes
precedence over other things your dry
cleaning pick up that day your
professional networking commitments your
job she's saying when you're in the
justice system that comes first
right picking up your dry cleaning just
same as a presidential election joining
us now Victor Davis Hanson Hoover
institution senior fellow Victor
um by any means necessary they want him
out they wanted to not allow him to win
in 2016 but before he even wins the
nomination which you know if you know we
don't anything can happen I guess but
right now you'd say odds are huge that
he'll win it then they want to make sure
that he can't campaign and then they
want to make sure that even if he wins
he still won't be president you see a
pattern here of what's happening with
this this crowd
yeah I think the subtext is what they're
not talking about and so they feel they
have no other choice for three reasons
one they can't run on Joe Biden's agenda
not on the border not on crime not in
the economy not on energy not on
anything and two Joe Biden is one trip
away from Oblivion he's one silly remark
away from Oblivion he's failing
geometrically at a geometric way and
whether he even finishes his term
they're unsure and then third to use
that left phrase that walls are closing
in it's not just
Archer and bobolinsky or the IRS
whistleblowers it's Victor shulkin it's
some oligarchs that say they have tapes
there's the hunter laptop that's being
re-examined for where he admits he gave
half his income to Joe and so they don't
want to talk about any of those three
things so it's Trump all the time and
when you look at latita James has a 250
million dollar lawsuit against Trump on
this sort of bogus idea of over
inflating real estate and then you look
at Alvin
Bragg and then you look at Jack Smith
and Fanny Willis and you look at all the
dates that they're talking about and you
superimpose them on a calendar and you
could Envision these 91 indictments plus
the civil suits and there's another
civil suit as well it might be almost
three or four days a week all the way to
election and it really shows you that
they're paranoid and they don't have any
confidence in a positive message or a
positive vibrant candidate and so it's
to get
Donald Trump fixate on Donald Trump or
whoever would get the nomination I've
never seen anything like this before
yeah I mean I don't think they even have
any pretense anymore Laura of Saint Joe
had a very successful yeah there's no
campaign
no not going to campaign he's not going
to campaign he's not going to debate
he's not going to really ever do a hard
interview with anyone he can't we all
know that the Press is going to campaign
for him and it's going to be Trump trial
24 7. uh Victor my question to you is
will this just over time will it wear on
the Republican electorate or Harden
their support for Trump as the
persecuted representative of the people
that I don't think anybody knows because
we've never been in these waters before
but right now it's obviously gaining
them empathy because of the sheer
Injustice of it but we don't know what
it will be like if for the wearied
electorate in three or four months or if
another candidate might say I'm I'm
going to be more effective in paying
these people back or reforming the doj
on behalf of trump then Trump can
because we don't know the what these
limitations are he's like a he's like
Gulliver with all these little putians
I've got these strings ropes tying him
down we don't know the effect on the
voter who wants to help him but may not
be able to and so and we don't know how
far whether we get tired of it or
whether we get angry with it right now
it's pretty clear people are angry and
they're showing empathy but I don't know
what they're going to be doing in
September or October November and he
said we can go on and on and on they're
banking on they're banking I think the
Democrats themselves have any idea what
they're doing as far as public opinion
They Don't Really Care they're just
obsessed and fixated on Donald Trump and
they do not want to talk about this
failed presidency this failing
cognitively failing president Ukraine
and the prettiest one of the most
corrupt political families in
presidential history they can't talk
about any of those three things no
Victor there's another another
interesting thing that we mentioned this
maybe two or three weeks ago about Judge
Tanya but it Bears repeating that she
worked at the law firm boy Schiller
flexner from 2002 until she was
confirmed to the bench in 2014. now boy
Schiller has strong connections to the
Democrats to Hunter Biden he was um he
was of council at the firm from 2009 to
um
this is all just a coincidence I'm sure
yeah why are these four prosecutors why
aren't any of them rhinos or
Independents or Republicans why isn't
there somebody in Utah or West Virginia
there it's not Fannie Willis probably
wants to be Governor she's a hard
leftist she's taught she's been bragging
about uh going after Trump ditto the
same thing with Bragg letita James ditto
Jack Smith has members of his family
that have involvement with the Obamas so
they all are conflicted but they don't
make any pretense they don't care it's
almost as if they're saying to the
American people this is the way it is
yes we're biased but it's Trump and what
are you going to do about it yeah
I've never seen any anything so
audacious it's beyond parody I think
they want people to think it it's
pointless to fight back to vote to
anything to object or to say you're not
going to comply it's just it's pointless
and they want to demoralize people and I
think Americans have to just decide for
themselves do they want a country or not
Victor thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else